le monde agricole change la chambre
d'agriculture du cher nous a donné
rendez-vous avec georgia une nouvelle
formule de rencontres entre
entrepreneurs agricoles innovants et
distributeurs grossistes un business
meeting de huit minutes pour convaincre
lui entretient maximum par participant
un vrai plus pour denis et ses graines
on sait pas trop forcé mangouste ap on
sait pas trop comment gérer
l'intégralité des des choses à faire
entre la partie pur techniques de tri de
graines la production la partie
conditionnement et puis après derrière
il faut aller vendre mais en même temps
on a d'autres choses à faire et c'est
vrai que c'est un petit peu compliqué la
possibilité de nous donner le sur une
matinée donné la possibilité de
rencontrer ces gens-là c'est hyper
intéressant
les porteurs de projets se succèdent
arnaud agriculteur local veut développer
son business de pop corn bio micro
ondable d'un produit qui est convivial
c'est un produit que j'ai pu partager en
famille que j'ai pu partager avec les
équipes avec qui je travaille et sur
lequel on a trouvé un consensus et je
trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de gens je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
trouvent un consensus autour ce produit
qui est très sympa des produits
innovants qui touche les distributeurs
aujourd'hui avoir une alternative pour
le consommateur c'est très important
donc son produit moi je suis aussi fou
que lui j'ai envie en fait de le tester
un magasin et proposer une alternative
avec les ans j'ai découvert des fruits
et légumes j'ai découvert des
ingrédients pour des salades
j'ai découvert des emballages qui
correspondent parfaitement à nos
attentes et surtout aux attentes de nos
consommateurs des consommateurs acteurs
des circuits courts qui veulent faire
travailler leurs agriculteurs et toutes
ces personnes sont à la fois des
entrepreneurs mais aussi pour beaucoup d
agriculteurs donc qui connaissent leur
métier qu'ils ont on va dire tirer aussi
des enseignements de leur leur métier et
des attentes des consommateurs
l'accompagnement georgia a le rôle de
facilitateur pour ces rencontres et veut
être aussi un accélérateur de tous ces
projets
k